guess who's at it again those jews
earlier this week israel fired a warning
shot into the armpit of the world
commonly referred to as syria now you
may not have heard of this news because
it was a relatively peaceful retaliatory
warning shot fired back into syria after
several rockets had made their way to
israel
you probably have heard of the exchange
of rockets between israel and hamas now
as people have died and that's always
front page news
now i realize that a lot of people out
there have an opinion on the subject
don't exactly know the history so i'm
going to try and wrap up everything you
need to know in about
three minutes post holocaust in 1948 as
the jewish state of israel became
formally and internationally recognized
it was immediately attacked by myriad
arab armies who were trying to
exterminate israel openly off the face
of the earth
now knowing that is key as we fast
forward to the war of 67 which is most
commonly seen as the crux of today's
anti-semitic leftist
arguments in 67 the dictator of egypt
openly said that he was going to
extinguish israel from the face of the
earth
syria and jordan said hey that sounds
like a party we're in
they literally acted as thugs attempting
to jump israel in an alleyway
you are a jew
leftists today are still mad that israel
did not allow themselves to be mugged
hey are you seeing what i'm seeing yeah
that juice fighting back oh does he
think he is
stay down but being forewarned of their
extermination because the arab leaders
are a stupid people
israel acted first and won the war in
turn proving that they were not in fact
the weak
feeble stereotypes commonly seen on arab
television but there were more of the
tough old jews from the school of
charles bronson
you tried to take me out you punk
let's dance you duke
so yes in the war of 67 israel did in
fact gain land while trying to not be
wiped off the face of the earth
with much of that land having since been
given away in hopes of achieving peace
instead this newly acquired land has
often been used as a launching pad for
rocket fire into israel's civilian
territories
what can you expect from an opposition
who believes in the official motto of
no recognition no negotiation and no
peace
fast forward to today when leftists
often not understanding the history of
israel decide to side against the one
enclave of human rights found in the
middle east and instead
side with nations who can legally beat
their women and
hang their gaze i stand with palestine
yes leftists disregarding all statistics
logic or historical context you should
be supporting israel
if only for the gays otherwise they're
here
they're queer they're dead at the end of
the day israel has recognized that
palestinians have a right to a state
on the flip side palestinian leaders
believe that the state of israel and
jews have no right to exist
period and if you support these leaders
and their nations
so do you what do you think comment
below fact is that there's never been an
autonomous palestinian muslim or arab
state in that small shred of land
and if history has showed us anything
it's that the jews are likely there to
stay
if you can't make peace with that and
instead choose to side with the nations
trying to commit mass
genocide against them well do so at your
own risk
you want some puke bag
come and get it